[Music]
we just got the word this week that the
roseanne reboot reboot is coming back
without her table and it's just gonna be
called the Connors what do you think
about that you know I think it's tough
that society has come to a place where
like we can't even take a joke anymore
you know what I mean like I grew up on
Roseanne and I don't I don't see no
wrong on Roseanne really yeah I mean
she's a comedian if we can't take a joke
that we got you know what I mean I think
you're gonna get some pushback we'll see
we'll see we'll see I mean I just I want
me I want us to all get along you know I
mean I think we shall be able to
co-exist and in the meantime I'll be
able to joke about it cuz it's funny
et spoke with Straight Outta Compton
star Jason Mitchell on the red carpet of
the 28th TV et Awards what you looking
forward to tonight looking forward to
seeing Jamie cut up and my last Beauty
Awards we're here with backstage most of
the time together just cracking jokes so
yeah well let's see so this should be
good I feel like every movie you step in
it's already like Oscar buzz award show
but what is it about the the Jason
Mitchell touch you know I'm just I'm
just wrong I'm just wrong and I'd give
it to the people as real as I can you
know I mean like I'm a heavy critic so
I'm always hard on myself like if I'm
gonna go see this movie I'm not gonna be
in it you know what I mean and I just I
just try to keep it as real as possible
people seem to like that
[Music]
[Applause]